怎么赚钱啊?
最简单的赚钱的方法就是交别人怎么赚钱
这句话是对的
而且这是一条非常优秀的方法论
我自己都没赚到钱我怎么交别人赚钱呢
所以首先你应该自己赚到钱怎么赚
我教你一些非常举的方法就没不失贸的告诉你
首先第一个
你要经常喝别人讨论怎么赚钱?就我们很多人一弹钱就不好意思开口
什么原因啊?
就是你鼓努力认为赚钱那个事好像是不光台的
这个脑子有问题啊
这个世界
现在最简单最有效的方法
就是给这个社会或者他人创造价值
让生活让他人变得更美好
从而获得财富
对吧,你看看马测
对吧,你看看沙漠他们
你就明白这个道理了
但是为什么我们会有这个思想呢
我们更糟糕的一个思想是什么
我们从小的时候没人交我们赚钱
然后我们又不喝别人讨论赚钱
那我这个赚钱的方法从来呢
靠自己物
不是你是个天才吗
所以我可能有的时候他有意思啊
就在网上有人一交你
怎么赚钱
第一反应是这个人一定是个骗子
是不是
当然了,这个原因是什么
就好的说
那个马测是骗了很多
有很多骗人的
难道这个问题的根本原因不是你自己没有独立思考的
判断的能力吗
我是说一个特别常见的事啊各位
你们是怎么使用的
是不是
有什么问题
大把子当速退引擎
就直接问
我还有一些人特别有意思
觉得这些好情愤
这看到一个知识我讲到特别好
然后把这个东西把那个练接给了AI
然后让这个AI帮你总结
这个人讲到什么东西有哪些知点是不是
是不是
九菜
你看看你们在这个公众中有没有判断的
有没有独立思考呢
正确的时候的AI的方法那不是这样的吗
你把这个知识传给AI
然后让他告诉你这个内容讲的是什么
然后马上问
他这个观点正确吗
有哪些漏洞
有哪些邏輯上不合理的地方
有没有一些边界条件和潜日条件
难道是不是这样的吗
我们很多人有默认习惯了
条件
就是总结别人在思想和传点然后拿来就用
所以各位
其实这个概念啊我们从小的时候没人交
我们怎么赚钱
如果我们刺激还不就讨论赚钱
你的知识从哪来呢
不是这个世界各九菜人太多了
正正的问题是我们刺激没有独立思考没有判断的同意
第二不是什么
还真好有人在吃过的时候就问了我
就说
关键是没有靠普的老师
找不到靠普的老师
找不到靠普的老师的问题吗
这个世界扣不到是很多呀
差点蛮高知道起来的
他明明确实地告诉你
他的钱是怎么转的
对不对
三抹奥德曼
然后这个马斯克他们都写是制的
哥哥用我
那玩耳
小儿美的做什么
对吧张英明他创意的时候他
他的想法的方法都是写的网络上的
张超龙把他的整个日制都写过来的
是不是
怎么都还差不多的老师吗
所以真正的问题不是没找不到靠普的老师
是最黑老师不为你呀
哎呀你们不会我呀你们不会我怎么吃的
这是我很多人最大的问题呀
就没有注动学习的能力
这个这个很搞笑的
我们学的十多年
军人不知道怎么学习
是不是
那怎么学习呢
我告大家已经非常吃到的方法
其实我的处理得写过了
我家这些马里边
关于
学习这个部分
然后给大家解释一下怎么学习呀
首先第一个把输毒薄
什么叫把输毒薄呢
找到那些真正转到前来的
而且真的把自己的想法
切到网络上的人已经被厌人弄过的人
找到他们的不回合找过他的书记
然后把他关键的之前拿过来
让给
然后你让他毒薄吗
送你
他在端知识的核心是什么
他到底讲的是什么东西
对不对如果你不会怎么办你告诉他说
请你用费慢的方法
讲给我
一个
那些年纪的学生
一个出伦变的学生
直到他讲回维持
第二个部分
结构某核心和随空下
对吧然后你说
请你找到他所提到的
他用到的结构
他提到随某核心和随空下把它列出来
要一步一步的门一步一步的学
你知道AI的作用是什么呀
最重要的作用不是帮你写东西
最帮的一个能力是逆向工程
对吧我给大家几个的简单例子吧比如说你不会写了你张
你不会拍视频
我就不会不说拍视频的拍视频的可能帮我疯了
我们说写了你张嘛
对不对这个
其实罗议是一样的
找到一条
找到
你想学习的那个人
对他的文章写得特别好
包括
把这篇文章的那个龙直接任务AI
那龙
给他
被人心高他
这个作者是什么样的背景
这篇文章出来以后有多少的约多样
有多少的评论
评论你是怎么说的
发过去
然后你让他跟你分节
这篇文章为什么好在哪
从里边里边有每些
可以借用的结构
模型和思维朋友
这个我今天说特别清楚了
提取自己成功的方法
提取他人成功的方法吧
对不对提取完了以后
原来他的方法他的朋友是这样的好好学习
是这么学吗我们好在把这条学习你不对
学完了以后想想
我怎么用在我的身上
然后完了
问
说来你以来考我
他这一本都用的一个知识你看我会还是不会
然后他问你然后你就会答
对不对
然后怎么
厌众思组也怎么厌众思组也怎么厌众思组也
所以我现在也想写一篇文章
对吧他这个类似的文章
来你以来我们一部一篇文章然后一篇我说
说完了以后从今书里成文章
把这个文章放上去有相应的数据有内容
回过来从今一一种
学习更多人的方法
然后不断的学习不断的分会
这不是学习的方法就这么简单
我们好多人学习不小一定要包括班
没有老师就不会觉得我们没有注动学习的能力呀
所以给你看
注动学习
是不是就意味着你比人更早的获得知识
这叫什么这叫新西昱昱昱
越来越多了一次考
这叫什么这叫认识差
你有的是马上去做干什么学书吗你有形怒上
这难道不是赚钱最重要的三个能力吗
是不是
所以呢你赚到钱
这是我们普通人最应该掌握的基本技能啊
不是赚多少
不是赚大钱赚很多很多钱不是
是赚到钱能赚到钱
这是最基本的技能为什么因为唯大的自由
唯大的自由需要经济基础
所以你看你打发转到一点钱
你就可以别人分享了
你就可以别人想了我没有撒谎呀我就告诉你我什么怎么转钱的
我打发转了一些我就告诉你怎么转钱的
是不是呢
所以各位
这个目的不是赚钱呀是通过交别人赚钱
学到赚钱的方法呀
这个位这句话是不是特别有道理的
怎么赚钱呀最好的赚钱方法就是交别人怎么赚钱
你自己都没有赚到钱怎么交别人呢
所以首先要去学习
怎么赚钱
学习赚钱的方法是我们应该掌握的最基本的技能
而最好的
能够让我们得到成长的方法
就是学习
怎么赚钱